[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
despite the countless Dragon Ball games
that have appeared since the manga
debuted in the mid 80s the series has
never needed them to sustain its
popularity most are forgettable some are
good but even fewer are truly great
thanks to developer our system works
particular talents Dragonball Fighters
is one of the great ones if not the best
yet whether still or in motion fighters
art looks like Dragonball at it's very
best
adhering closely to the standards set by
series creator Akira Toriyama and no
matter how you may have watched the show
the option to choose between Japanese
and English voice acting makes it easy
to feel connected to the events on
screen you can't let your guard down
even if you've already won within the
convincing Dragon Ball shell is a fast
paced 3v3 tag-team fighting game that
will feel familiar to Marvel vs. Capcom
3 veterans but despite a few familiar
parallels fighters is distinctly
Dragonball every character can jet
through the air in a flash at any time
toss energy blasts like it's nothing and
unleash a flurry of small punches and
kicks to stagger a hesitant opponent
these super beings are incredibly
powerful and fighters translates that
energy to the screen perfectly
it also makes it easy for anyone to tap
into that power with relatively short
special attack lists and one button or
two button activations for Universal
mechanics like any great fighting game
fighters doesn't lose depth just because
it's accessible super attacks and
teleports are easy to pull off but they
come with timing and combo conditions
that allow for expert level analysis and
strategic play it's also important to
properly manage the lone meter that
fuels most of your special abilities a
setup that makes fighters next move more
unpredictable than usual compared to
some games with multiple abilities
specific meters of course you also don't
have to be an aspiring online competitor
to enjoy fighters as it includes a
significant story mode that can last a
dozen hours or more if you seek out
every possible cutscene while a [ __ ]
run out in places and relatively easy
until the conclusion it's still a treat
for Dragon Ball fans with plenty of new
vignettes starring classic characters
Dragon Ball super characters on the
roster notwithstanding but the plot is
split into three arcs you are
technically seeing one arc from
different perspectives with a few
alternate events to keep things
interesting because there's practically
zero times spent introducing you to
characters or their world it's difficult
to imagine how a newcomer to Dragon Ball
would understand things like the ginyu
forces proclivity to pose dramatically
or the reason why Crillon doesn't have a
nose let alone the broad concepts of
Super Saiyans and Dragon Balls
then again the mix of oddball antics and
hyper serious face offs is inherently
appealing for the confident cartoon
expression on display which requires no
additional context to enjoy as in combat
arcs capable design skills make the 3d
models and environments and cut scenes
look stunningly close to actual 2d
animation there are moments when you
feel like you're watching a new episode
of Dragon Ball Z but there is a catch
you're forced to press a button to
advance dialog rather than allowed to
kick back and watch the show when
fighters gets a colon close to
recreating the look of the anime the
force interaction feels like a step in
the wrong direction albeit a minor one
in the grand scheme of things story
modes real downfalls how repetitive it
becomes you fight clones of only a
portion of the games overall roster ad
nauseam each chapter is presented like a
map locations connected by a branching
path in order to get to the chapter boss
you have to navigate the board and pick
and choose your fights
the way given that there are optional
pathways in each chapter and that you
can concoct your own team it's not
surprising to learn that there are
optional cutscenes to unlock depending
on these conditions despite the rewards
being largely enjoyable after a handful
of hours fighting lackluster opponents
the idea of replaying story chapters to
see a quirky character interaction is
unfortunately one that's easy to
sideline
similarly the game's basic small over
world feels unnecessary even though it
attempts to add value modes are divided
among spokes around a circular hub and
you can run around as small versions of
the game's characters sometimes an
alternate outfits the game tries to earn
your interest through unlockable avatars
but even if this sounds good you can
only earn them through randomized loot
boxes you earn money as you fight and
complete story mode milestones and these
can be cashed in for a capsule which
turns into a random cosmetic item there
unfortunately no alternate costumes
available for combat rather than harm
the game this system just feels
unnecessary as none of the rewards are
critical to enjoying what matters most
participating in explosive battles and
enjoying interactions between Dragon
Balls lovably bizarre characters though
merely a small piece of the overall
puzzle the rare dramatic finishes are
perhaps the most respectable and
impressive nod to fans in fighters
anyone who spent years watching Dragon
Ball Z unfold over nearly 300 episodes
will gasp the first time they trigger
one which will only happen with certain
matchups on her particular conditions
they have nothing to do with fighters
story but they have everything to do
with the revered history of the series
at large
[Music]
before you might have oh you put the
back fighters is complex and distinct
enough to be enjoyed by fighting game
competitors but there's no question that
it's been designed to tap into the
hearts of Dragon Balls most dedicated
fans and no doubt those same qualities
will win people over who've never given
the series a chance before where past
games attempted to get there through
huge rosters and deliberately
predictable trips down memory lane
fighters has bottled the essence of what
makes the series characters animation
and sense of humor so beloved and
reconfigured it into something new a
Dragon Ball fighting game that can go
toe-to-toe with the best of the genre
[Music]
[Music]
Camilla marker wood chips